massive breaking news in the Trump
Russia scandal I want to tell you about
remember that a trump campaign chairman
Paul Manafort was found guilty on eight
counts I believe it was a few weeks ago
and there was a mistrial on some of
those counts as well and I told you at
the time that it's not even close to
over for Paul Manafort this is just the
beginning of it's going to be a very
very long and possibly extraordinarily
damaging legal drama for him and those
other cases are also not going well and
now at the big news is that Paul
Manafort has flipped he's agreed to
plead guilty in a different case and to
cooperate with special prosecutor Robert
Muller and his investigation and this is
just a massive turnaround and it shows
that this is a very bad situation for
Paul Manafort obviously as if we didn't
know that but it's also potentially a
really bad situation for Donald Trump
you might remember that Donald Trump
previously said that manna fort was the
brave one sort of like as opposed to
Michael Cohen because manna fort wasn't
cooperating he was refusing to flip and
cooperate with special prosecutor Robert
Muller this was thought of as sort of
like a signal to manna for right from
Trump Trump sending this tweet where
he's effectively saying don't blab and
I'll pardon you on the backend at some
point and now we don't know exactly what
the sentence will be but guilty pleas in
conjunction with a cooperation agreement
are very very different than guilty
verdicts which we saw a couple of weeks
ago in that mana fort has realized that
the case against him is so serious that
he's better off even with the
possibility of this pardon from Donald
Trump kind of lurking in the background
he realized he's better off working with
Robert Moeller and Renato Mariotti is a
former federal prosecutor and he
explained that a cooperation agreement
is binary either you're cooperating or
you aren't you can't say if you are
manna for
well I'm willing to cooperate and talk
about Jared Kushner but not about what
Donald Trump did and he explained this
in a Twitter threat which we'll put up
on the screen for you today prosecutors
with molars office announced that mana
Ford's plea agreement in the DC case was
a cooperation agreement that is big news
mana fort has agreed to tell muller
everything he knows about potential
potential criminal activity by anyone
the DOJ does not let defendants
cooperate as to some people but not
others if a defendant cooperates they
have to provide the government with
truthful and complete answers to any
question and be willing to testify in
any matter they are asked to be a
witness in for that reason mana Ford is
not cooperating against one person in
particular he's agreed to say everything
he knows and in order to receive a deal
he had to already begin doing so
prosecutors don't give deals until after
the defendant provides useful info this
also means that mana Ford has something
of value to offer Moeller Moeller would
not have given him a deal unless mana
fort was able to help muller
make a case against someone else or
significantly strengthened an existing
case and this gets us back to the
reasons why the possibility of a pardon
isn't good enough for Mann afford to
stay quiet the assets that mana Ford
would potentially have to forfeit would
be forfeited period that wouldn't be
impacted by a pardon down the line by
President Trump those assets would be
gone the charges that Moeller agrees not
to move forward with could still be
filed later at the state level and as we
know state-level charges cannot be
pardoned meaning mana fort would still
be at risk and then lastly and this is
sort of like the key point of this
entire thing and Renato Mariotti makes
this point in those tweets prosecutors
make cooperation deals in order to snag
bigger fish or to get stronger
charges more serious charges against
people they already believe they're
going to be able to indict what that
tells us is that if Robert Muller is
willing to give mana for a deal it's
because he believes it's going to help
him get bigger charges against bigger
players mana Ford is a pretty big player
he was Trump's campaign Chairman and
that's already massive when you have
this amount of criminal guilt on the
behalf of the guy who was running
Trump's campaign for a period over that
summer of 2016 and it's a signal as to
how much bigger it might get so what we
go back to here is the bigger narrative
that I told you about last week
increasingly what we have are Trump's
cronies in trouble more and more serious
charges more and more indictments and of
course this is really important no
exculpatory moment no indication that
this is a witch hunt or bogus or an
empty investigation and now what I want
to briefly touch on is the hilarious
u-turn from the Trump administration
about Paul Manafort as a result of Paul
manna for flipping which sent the Trump
administration into an absolute and
total tailspin and that's what I'm going
to talk to you about next today's
episode of the show is made possible in
part by purple mattress if you spent the
night tossing and turning couldn't sleep
maybe you've got stress or pain that's
keeping you up at night you've got to
try purple mattress made with a brand
new material that was developed by an
actual rocket scientist
the purple mattress will feel different
than anything you've experienced because
unlike traditional memory foam the
purple material is both soft and firm at
the same time so it's supportive and
comfortable plus it's breathable so it
sleeps cool and with there a hundred
night risk free trial if you're not
fully satisfied you can return it for a
full refund not to mention it's backed
by a 10-year warranty with free shipping
and returns you are going to love purple
and right now my viewers and listeners
can get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress
in addition to the great gifts that
they're offering site-wide go to purple
comm use the code Pakman at checkout
that is purple comm code PA k ma n the
only way to get the free pillow is to
use my code Pakman at checkout that's
purple comm code is PA k ma n